I am so pleased to be presenting the
Award for Best Original Song like the
great movie music of years past this
year's nominees create emotional
highlights that reflect hope and
jubilation as well as love heartbreak
and loss you've heard them all perform
tonight once again here are the nominees
for best original film audition the full
two dreams from Lala Wayans music by
Justin Horwich lyrics by Benj Catholic
and Justin Paul can stop the feeling
controlled music and lyrics by Justin
Timberlake Max Martin and Karl Johan
Schuester Cydia stars from la la land
music by Justin her written lyrics by
Benj Patrick and Justin Paul the mg
chairs from Jen the james foley story
music and lyrics by Jai Ralph and spin
how far I'll go from Alana music in
verse by Lin Manuel
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Justin Hurwitz Ben
plastic and Justin Hall for city of
stars lala land
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the songwriting team of Justin ervis
been Catholic and Justin coughs are also
nominated in this category for the song
audition the foolish dream Justin take
home his second Oscars tonight
all right I'm gonna really quickly try
to make a lot of people here really good
Eric James Meyers Amy Dunning Ryan sense
and Lenny wool ken Palin Julie Fontaine
Kristin Kirkland Jennison naomi nori
Lisa Tabak and Albert Loa miss Newman
keeps a chick the Glen brundin the whole
music team Mary Steve Nick Jason Eldad
and Tony Tyler thank you to Justin for
your beautiful and glorious music thank
you to Damian you inspired every single
word that we wrote for me I want to
thank my wife my little girl at home my
family who's here I thank God for you
guys and you know I was educated in
public schools where the where as arts
and culture were valued and recognized
in resource and I'm so grateful to all
my teachers who taught so much and gave
so much to us one thing our producers
mark Fred and Jordan oh my god I'm
actually freaking out right now
oh I wonder I want to thank Richard
crafts and Joma Jota I want to thank my
mom who is amazing in my day tonight
and she let me quit the JCCC Soccer
League to be in a school musical so this
is dedicated to all the kids who sing in
the rain and all the moms who let them
thank you very much